a deer a female deer
ray a drop of golden sun
me a name i call myself
far a long long way to run
hi and welcome to rt essentials it's
nikki novak here and i can sing
actually i'm so sorry nobody needed to
hear that what you do need to hear
though is what we've got in store for
you this week in our rundown of the best
most magically harmonic toe-tappingly
contagious dramatically affecting movie
musical adaptations ever now a couple of
notes here nothing in minor key please
it's out of my range i'm not a baritone
soprano there are caveats for what
qualified for this list we're talking
best musical adaptations so only films
that originated on the stage
so sorry la la land bye ryan farewell
wizard of oz is on down that yellow
brick road second we didn't include any
entries that were exclusively the stage
production put on film so unfortunately
buh-bye hamilton
that means you and all the others like
it for the rest we tried to keep our
solos short and sweet so we're sticking
with the most essential movie musicals
ones where the films though based on
live production stand by themselves as
significant pieces of cinema
apologies to all the cats stands out
there but being the longest running show
on broadway just isn't gonna cut it for
our criteria this week cats was
basically a really long snapchat filter
for everyone else feel free to hum along
if you know it i can't cause a copyright
so you do it for me in this week's rt
essentials best movie musical
adaptations
the whiz
[Music]
1978 the wiz was an urban reimagining of
frank l bomb's classic story in which
harlem was kansas new york was oz the
wicked witch ran a sweatshop the good
witch ran numbers and the man behind the
curtain was a failed politician from
wait for it
atlantic city oof
that it's a little bit too close to home
the whiz had maybe one of the most
stacked casts in musical movie history
with diana ross as dorothy leno horn as
the good witch mabel king as the wicked
witch of the west richard pryor as the
wiz and a 19 year old michael jackson as
the scarecrow joel schumacher's
screenplay was an extremely loose
adaptation of william f brown's 1974
broadway liberato though schumacher had
seen the broadway production he used
none of the wiz's book which is just
fancy theater slang for spoken dialogue
which is also just fancy theater slang
for all the talky parts between the song
quincy jones was hired to help with
arranging the music and providing
original songs for the film
[Music]
the production incorporated many iconic
new york locations into oz including the
cyclone at coney island the 1960 ford's
world fair new york state pavilion and
the world trade center for the
glittering oz oscar de la renta designed
many of the costumes in the film though
a critical and commercial flop the movie
gained second life through home video
sales where it became a cult classic and
helped propel a then 19 year old michael
jackson to solo super stardom in 2015
nbc completed the circle of life by
readapting the wiz into a staged
production for the wiz alive it
literally eased on down the road the
rocky horror picture show
and brad and janet my name is brad
maters just a couple of clean-cut kids
this is my fiancee jared weiss brad
magers and janet weiss are a newly
engaged couple whose car breaks down at
the palace of dr frankenfurter in 1975's
the rocky horror picture show richard
o'brien wrote directed and co-starred in
rocky horror which he originally
conceived of as a theatrical love letter
to the classic horror and sci-fi genre
it's also a total celebration of queer
culture as the uptight brad and janet
soon find themselves swept up in the
time warp again unaware that their
self-proclaimed sweet transvestite host
is actually an alien from the planet
transylvania
[Music]
the story is strange for tonight
is the night and my beautiful creature
is destined to be full
rocky horror marked the theatrical movie
debut of tim curry who originated the
role of frankenforder on the london
stage in 1973 alongside o'brien patricia
quinn mel campbell and jonathan adams
his co-stars also reprised their roles
in the film but there was at least one
notable addition to the cast for janet
majors o'brien cast a young susan
sarandon in her first ever starring role
this isn't the junior chamber of
commerce brad there's a mad scientist
named frank n furter come up to the lab
and see what's on the slab originally
played in theaters during the afternoon
rocky heart bombed hard i mean hard
unsurprisingly due to its extremely
risque subject matter but found a rabid
cult-like fan base through a peculiar
avenue hybrid screenings where the movie
would play in a theater simultaneously
to performers who would stand in front
of the screen and act out in the entire
show
these midnight screenings of rocky
horror became a cultural milestone and a
rite of passage that still continues to
this day
princess diana was such a big fan she
requested a meeting with tim curry after
one of his other plays telling him that
the rocky horror picture show had
quite completed my education
west side story
[Music]
all right now come on shoot it and shoot
it
[Music]
okay so bear with me a little bit as we
trace back the origins of jerome robbins
and robert wise west side story the 1961
adaptation of leonard bernstein and
steven sondheim's broadway musical which
itself was a retelling of shakespeare's
romeo and juliet
the musical swapped out verona for new
york's upper east side in the 1950s
foreshadowing two trends we'll be seeing
a lot of in this episode musicals based
on plays based on other source material
and adaptations which relocate the
central action to the same 10 square
blocks in new york oh
and murder these musicals love
themselves a good homicide preferably in
song form
so sorry it was an original
don't steal it
[Music]
unlike our previous entries west side
story was a huge hit like highest
grossing film of 1961 kind of hit like
110 out of its 11 oscar nominations kind
of hit including best picture i mean
that's success the film starred natalie
wood and rita moreno russ tamblyn and
richard baimer belting out bangers like
america tonight and i feel pretty in
between bangs of their guns because yeah
lots of gang violence in this one folks
but you know the kind that inspire
impromptu ballet brawls between the jets
and the sharks with steven spielberg's
2021 remake we are just hoping for even
more snappy pirouettes to make all this
systemic racism faced by the puerto
rican sharks a little bit easier to
swallow
[Music]
les miserables
[Music]
in 2012 tom hooper dreamed a dream for
les miserables based on the longest
running musical of london's west end
this was pre-cat's remember and we still
allowed hooper to dream for late miz he
imagined a soundtrack not pre-recorded
in advance to be later mimed on camera
but captured live in the moment as the
actors moved around sets built to look
like the paris uprising of 1832 this was
the largest attempt to create a
naturally ambient musical
a world that's full of happiness
[Music]
i love him
this was the first movie musical where
actors led the pace of their own song
something fans either really liked or
really hated because it was that much
harder to sing along to anne hathaway
hugh jackman and russell crowe making up
their own individual rhythms as they
went along and what's the point of a
musical if you can't sing it in time but
ultimately it won critics over at least
enough to have it be the first musical
nominated for best pictures since
chicago in 2002 while it didn't win
hathaway alone scored the oscar for best
supporting actress as fantine
les mis is a sung through musical
meaning there are no breaks where people
are just you know talking like normal
people between songs nope every scene
every plot development and every line of
dialogue occurring during light biz
which takes place to be clear over three
separate periods of time is sung by the
characters
[Music]
without him
the world around me changes the trees
are burned everywhere the streets are
full of strangers
while most of the cast was well known
actors hugh jackman amanda seyfried anne
hathaway russell crowe eddie redmayne
sasha barron cohen and helena bottom
carter the role of eponine was played by
samantha barks making her on-screen
debut
barks was playing eponine in the west's
end stage production of les miz when she
got the call telling her she'd been cast
in her very first movie if the set looks
familiar for the battle of the
revolutionary students against the
french government and maybe because
you've seen it pulling double duty it
also served as the set of diagon alley
for the harry potter films
fiddler on the roof
[Music]
a fiddler on the roof
[Music]
if i were a rich man saying israeli
actor topple in 1971's a fiddler on the
roof norman jewison's adaptation of the
broadway musical about the family of
tevye the milkman and their town of
anatevka during the turn of the century
russian pogroms now that doesn't sound
like the type of story that lends itself
to a lot of crowd pleasers
there's actually a surprising amount of
bops between matchmaker matchmaker if i
was a rich man sunrise sunset to life
and tradition there's a lot of toe
tappers in the bittersweet tale of
shtetl trying to keep out the dual
threats of anti-semitism and modern
culture fiddler on the roof was a huge
hit in japan where the themes of
crumbling tradition resonated with
audiences this is still my home
my land
get off my land
[Music]
fiddler received eight oscar nominations
and won three including a statue for
john williams for best adaptation and
original song score yeah they needed to
workshop that title a little bit to
create a naturalistic tone for the film
jewishian eschewed the staged
productions aesthetics and elected to
film fiddler on location mostly outdoors
and with an earth-toned palette he hired
famed director of photography oswald
norris known for creating unusual color
palettes on films such as the whiz the
man with the golden gun and oliver to
create fiddler's original color scheme
the sound of music how do you solve a
problem like mariah
how do you catch a cloud and pin it down
[Music]
across the decades one question has
plagued musical fans
how do you solve a problem like maria we
assume using a complex algebraic formula
that mathematicians have yet to discover
but in the interim
we had the sound of music robert wise's
lighthearted romp through nazi infested
austria
julie andrews and christopher plummer
co-star as the unlikely couple of maria
a fliberty gift nun and captain von
trapp the uptight widower with seven
kids someone really needs to examine why
all these movies are set against such
traumatizing backdrops this is why we
can't have our favorite things people
girls in white dresses with blue satin
sashes snowflakes that stay on my nose
and eyelashes silver white winters that
melt into springs these are a few of my
favorite things
to entertain the children between takes
andrews would sing a
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious
from mary poppins
since the film hadn't been released when
they were in production the kids all
thought the actress was just super
clever and made up the song just for
them the movie is based on maria von
trapp's 1949 memoir the story of the von
trapp family singers who really did
escape the nazis by fleeing through the
austrian alps to italy one day before
germany shut its borders though she was
invited as a guest of honor to the
opening of the musical the wartime
heroine received no such invitation for
the film adaptation hollywood you're
awful
after reaching out to a producer at 20th
century fox she was able to score a
preview of the film but was told it was
a no-go for the premiere which had
already sold out i mean come on people
to be fair they were probably expecting
her to need a plus 10
chicago
[Music]
[Music]
2002 was the time for slick bob fosse
chicago and all that jazz hands as we're
discovering most musical adaptations
tend to be a little bit dark and rob
marshall's cinematic retelling of the
1975 broadway hit was no exception the
story is entirely told through the pov
of a delusional murderess flapper named
roxy heart played by renee zellweger
roxy sees the world as a musical and
lying cheating and murdering is her
ticket to the starring role don't we all
after shooting her sidepiece roxy levels
up with a like-minded homicidal
celebrity velma kelly played by
catherine zeta-jones and lawyers up with
billy flynn an opportunistic defense
attorney played by richard gere
rounding out that incredible cast our
queen latifah as matron mama morton and
john c reilly as roxy's buffoonish
husband and oh did we mention that
roxy's inner life is such a three-ring
circus it warrants its own imaginary mc
played by tay diggs yeah
fosse's really not known for his
subtlety i'm not quite finished yet
face it roxy you ain't never gonna have
an axe you got connections i would have
said anything to get a piece of that
okay
[Music]
what you need is billy clinton chicago
broke big at the box office making
306 million dollars making it the
highest grossing musical movie of all
time it also won big at the oscars where
it earned 13 nominations and won six
including
ta-da best picture the story of chicago
has an mcu's worth of what-ifs charlize
theron was originally cast as roxy but
was dropped when reiner came on
beyonce wanted to play mama morton a
role given to kathy bates before she had
to drop out and the torch was passed to
queen latifah who got a best supporting
oscar nomination for the role but lost
to zeta jones who honestly deserved it
since she discovered she was pregnant
right before shooting started so that's
why they were putting all those bowler
hats and chairs in front of their
stomachs got it keep your paws off my
lawyer
sweetest little jazz killer ever to hit
chicago that's the angle i'm after
you were in the paper today too in the
back with the obituaries
they love me they love you a lot more if
you're a hang you know why because
there's no more papers
that's chicago america's obsession with
true crime can be traced back to
chicago's origin story the movie was
based on the broadway musical which was
adapted from a 1920s play about
real-life jazz murderess beulah annan
and belva gertner so in a way the duos
plan to slay their way into infamy
worked out
congratulations i think
little shop of horrors giving you
sunlight
i've given you rain
looks like you're not happy
unless
[Music]
before it was ever on broadway frank
oz's 1986 black comedy little shop of
horrors began as a throwaway bee film
from legendary producer roger corman
the first little shop of horrors was
born in 1960 over a bet the director had
with his brother that he could rehearse
and shoot an entire movie from the
ground up over the course of four days
using leftover sets from his previous
film
with those conditions i might have come
with something a little smaller in scope
than giant man-eating plant takes over
the world but you do you roger
of course the 1986 version was a much
grander spectacle as oz was no stranger
to the magic of puppeteering by the end
of the film when the carnivorous metapod
audrey 2 is at her full power it took 60
people to operate it properly
[Music]
bill murray stole almost the entire
movie by improvising his dialogue oz
trusted the snl alum to be able to play
opposite steve martin as the sadistic
oran scravello dds
giving the two only the most minimal of
onstage notes of what the scene was
supposed to be feed me all night long
how am i supposed to keep on feeding you
now i'm just a mean green brother
[Music]
the ending of oz's little shop of
horrors was originally much darker and
closer to the one in howard ashman and
alan mankin's original broadway
production in which seymour and audrey
are both eaten by audrey too there was
an elaborate musical number in the film
which saw the plant rampaging across the
world the studio however opted for the
more family-friendly version in which
seymour and audrey survive the attack
and kill the alien plant ah typical
hollywood so predictable but google
little shop of horrors original ending
and strap yourself in for a big giant
plant treat
[Music]
dream girls
400 a week to sing behind mr jimmy early
to on the road starting tomorrow morning
ladies thank you so much you're saving
jimmy's life come at your feet not do
anything for y'all exactly what would
you like jimmy to do for you bill
condon's 2006 dream girls is yet another
example of a film a clef or in this case
a jukebox a club which is that little
thing when a piece of fiction is
inspired by real life events but doesn't
want to get sued so it changes
everybody's name and some of the key
details nobody knows this in this case
dream girls was based on the 1981
broadway musical that took inspiration
from the origin story of motown records
and the formation and dissolution of the
supremes throughout the 60s and 70s
rights to the original film were
initially owned by the broadway show's
co-producer david geffen who imagined it
as a star vehicle for whitney houston
when geffen dissolved his studio to
co-found dreamworks in 1994 warner
brothers bought the rights for a joel
schumacher version starring lauren hill
but the project was shelved until it was
brought back to geffen as a dreamworks
title intending to cast relative
unknowns as a singing group of the
dreams to mirror the real life rise of
the detroit girl group
i know what's
happening i've been around
i don't believe this all can be
happening to me
miracles happen all the time baby though
it didn't exactly work out like that
after one beyonce knowles came to condon
expressing interest in playing dina the
shy backup member who becomes the lead
vocalist in place of their resident diva
effie white jamie foxx had originally
passed on the role of curtis taylor jr
when dreamworks wouldn't need his salary
but he sure changed his tune fast when
queen bae got involved eddie murphy
immediately accepted the part of jimmy
thunder early a crooner character based
on a mashup of james brown jackie wilson
and marvin gaye so much for a cast of
unknowns but that still left the movie
star effie up for grabs over 783
actresses auditioned for the role
including disney star raven simone and
american idol alums fantasia barino and
jennifer hudson as well as two actresses
who had starred in the broadway
production when hudson was finally cast
it would mark her big screen debut and
included the show-stopping number and i
am telling you i'm not going
to sing league what do you mean i always
sing leave
your dreams
change i'm talking change
i promise you i was gonna make you all
right
it paid off in a major way though
originally fans were disgruntled that
hudson was delegated to the best
supporting actress category in
dreamworks oscar campaign with beyonce
pushed to the front for best actress it
was hudson who took home the gold that
night one of two awards that dream girls
received from the academy
the film was notably absent from the
best picture category however making it
the first film to have the most
nominations in a single year without
winning for best
[Music]
valley balls
1972's hottest film was cabaret this
musical had everything liza minnelli a
sexually ambiguous mc an irl origin
story set in nazi germany and bob fosse
which is that thing where bob bossie
gets to direct his own musical's
adaptation and goes absolutely berserk
on set
using real animal guts in a scene where
minnelli's character finds her dog
murdered because who trusts actors to be
able to do their job right nellie
actually auditioned for the role of
sally bowles in the original broadway
production but gosh she was unknown at
one point she was turned down due to her
inexperience with the movie she was able
to achieve something her mother judy
garland never did which was win an oscar
seriously judy garland never won an
oscar okay i guess that makes it
official horror now has to share the
most snubbed oscar genre distinction
with musical adaptations because while
cabaret won eight oscars it lost best
picture and best adapted screenplay to
the godfather
i kinda get it but to this day fosse's
sexy wartime classic still holds the
record for winning the most academy
awards without cinching best picture
what good is sitting
all alone in your room
come
hear the music
play
the original camera negative of the film
has been long lost any restoration for
re-release in modern formats had to be
done frame by frame life may be a
cabaret old chum but restoring it's a
lot less fun
oh my gosh we're at the end
should i do a musical number shall i do
a song shall i do a dance i can hit my
mark so that concludes what's got to be
the darkest timeline of musical theater
adaptations
if you're out there thinking musicals
are all dear evan hansen and the
greatest showman hope this episode has
made you realize you are living in la la
land or just benji basic and justin paul
stands you tell me so did we include all
your favorite things are there a few
essential adaptive musicals that didn't
go grease lightning your way well don't
worry we're bound to sing their praises
in another essentials list so keep
watching this has been rt essentials i'm
nikki novak reminding you don't cry for
me argentina or just don't cry for
argentina we got a lot more content
coming your way right after this
[Music]
you